often care cancer care the sponsors of
this segment is here to help you and
your loved ones prevent cancer rocky
spoke to them to learn more
welcome back dr gallard it's been a
while
oh thank you so much rookie it's great
to be here great now we're talking
cancer prevention that is obviously an
extremely important topic um let's just
start with the basics of understanding
cancer and the struggles that you guys
are facing
absolutely well
the problem is really cancer is not just
one disease it's many diseases it's
characterized by an abnormal growth of
cells it can start in the lungs the
breasts the colon even the blood or bone
marrow and the cancer cells can spread
in a variety of ways
and as there are very many types of
cancer there are very many
ways in which cancer cancer can present
oftentimes it's quite insidious it
doesn't run up a flag and say hey i'm
here
people will have other constitutional
symptoms
and sometimes the cancer will present
at an advanced state and that makes it
much more difficult to treat
of course and
to prevent that from happening cancer
screenings are extremely important so
let's talk about what you guys offer in
terms of screenings for instance
mammograms are recommended at certain
prescribed times
for the prevention and early detection
of breast cancer
pap smears and the hpv test are
recommended
when looking for cervical cancer
colorectal cancer
almost always comes from pre-cancerous
polyps
so
we recommend periodic colonoscopies that
can range from anywhere from
you know five years down to one year and
some people who have
extremely high risk conditions to every
10 years to people who are low risk and
finally lung cancer
we even do recommend scans for some
people who are at high risk for
developing lung cancer so it's really
important to individualize risk and be
able to talk with your primary care
provider about what sort of cancer
prevention fits you
right and what about things people can
do at home to help prevent or the risk
of cancer
so lung cancer you know try to eliminate
smoking okay andy and even secondhand
smoke skin cancer
don't spend a lot of time in the sun or
cover yourself up really well or use
really really
good sorts of barrier
creams so you won't get all those
potentially harmful rays
limiting
alcohol
so
that you aren't at
so much risk for
cancers of the voice box
or or the mouth
and those
cancers are very much linked to
environmental toxins and exposures so
it's really really key to do what you
can in terms of the way you live your
life to
shall we say mitigate risk
thank you to optum care cancer care for
sponsoring this segment they have
locations across southern nevada just
call 702